the others have criticized you for using  the phrase Chinese virus how do you feel  about that you go to continue using that  phrase well China was putting out  information which was false that our  military gave this to them that was  false and rather than having an argument  I said I have to call it where it came  from it did come from China so I think  it's a very accurate term but no I  didn't appreciate the fact that China  was saying that our military gave it to  them our military did not give give it  anybody use no phrase creates a stigma  no I don't think so no I think saying  that our military gave it to them  creates a stigma